hey guys it's Monday my name's Jess I'm
dad and it's time the game for you
[Music]
destiny twos first major expansion curse
of Osiris is set to launch early next
month Game Director Luke Smith has come
out to tell us a bunch of things that
are changing in the update that's
arriving alongside the expansion
it's the classic changes list with Smith
listing economy updates investment
updates gameplay updates and more the
economy updates will affect vendors in
their gear as well as tokens and
legendary shards and investment updates
will come in the form of new reward
systems for weapons and armor customers
Cyrus is set on Mercury and will feature
new story elements and quests a new
level cap new weapons and new crucible
maps it launches on December 5th on ps4
Xbox one and PC along with Xbox 1x and
ps4 Pro enhancements you can pick up
curse of a cyrus as part of the game's
expansion pass and those of you yet to
jump into the Bungie space shooter can
pick up a free trial on all platforms
starting tomorrow November 28th the
trial will give you access to all Story
content on the first two planets earth
and Saturn's moon Titan as well as the
farm destiny twos social space quick
play in the crucible is also open as
part of the trial and all progress will
carry over to the full game should you
choose to pick it up the CEO of Square
Enix has weighed in on rumors that the
Deus Ex franchise is on hold it's not on
hold
oh sorry Adam
during an interview with games industry
biz josuke Matsuda wanted to correct
reports that Deus Ex had been put on
hold after the lackluster performance of
last year's Deus Ex mankind divided he
said we have never said anything about
discontinuing that title but for some
reason that's the rumor out on the
market what I can say is idols Montreal
has always developed Deus Ex and the
issue is we do not have limitless
resources of course it would be ideal if
we could work on all of them all the
time but the fact of the matter is some
titles will have to wait their turn they
wanted to say that Deus Ex is a very
important title for the publisher and
that Square Enix are discussing what to
do with the next installment so there
you go Deus Ex isn't dead elsewhere in
the interview Matsuda spoke about how a
lot of Square Enix's western studios are
working on Marvel licensed games
particularly Crystal Dynamics and
they're already announced Avengers
project he hyped the game saying I
believe that the level of game that
we're developing right now as far as I
have seen is amazing and you'll be
seeing news about it going forward I
make a point of regularly checking on
the build and to me it
looks amazing the game that caused me to
break at least one ps3 controller
demon's souls to many S's too many SS is
losing the support for its online
services the official Dark Souls Twitter
account revealed that online servers for
Demon Souls will be shut down across the
globe On February 28th of next year nine
years after launch Sony explained that
this will mean online multiplayer both
co-op and invasions leaderboards
wandering silhouettes bloodstains left
by other players and hints and messages
written by other players will no longer
be a part of the game that said Demon
Souls will still be playable offline the
boss fight with old boss which
originally involved fighting another
player will also now function
differently North American publisher
Atlas posted on its website it's with
mixed emotions we say goodbye to the
service countless players have enjoyed
demon souls and the functionality it
introduced to players when such things
were rarer that it's everything we've
got for you today do let us know what
you care about and remember we'll be
back every day after working week to
tell you about the gaming news things
that's Tuesday that's Wednesday Thursday
Friday Monday not Saturday and something
now that that points been believe it
will last the you tomorrow Tuesday
Wednesday just like holding